historically the Republican Party
represented the business class and let's
say the spirit of getting ahead
the Democrats represented
the average guy uh the spirit of the
fair shake and that held as sort of the
division of the two parties for most of
the 20th century but since the end of
the Industrial Age the Democrats have
become the party of professionals more
and more combined with non-whites and
other minority groups although those are
in play they're certainly not uh the the
property of the democratic party and to
the shock of a lot of Democrats
Latino voters moved over toward Trump in
2020 after four years of his presidency
and it's worth trying to understand why
that happened rather than assuming that
the Democrats are the party of inclusion
and the Republicans other party of white
males as some Democrats think so and the
Republican party has gone from being
that party of business of
um in some ways middle American Business
small town business as well as Corporate
America to the party of
essentially an angry
white working class that has fallen
further behind and has seen its place as
sort of the backbone of the country you
know the the Bedrock of a of American
democracy and capitalism and instead
their lives look more and more like the
lives of uh people in the cities who
suffer from drug addiction
um fatherless families
multi-generational poverty you see that
in all kinds of towns and rural areas
outside the big Metropolitan centers so
the Democrats have the big cities which
have become more and more prosperous and
better educated and the Republicans have
the Townsend Countryside which if in
many areas been sort of abandoned and so
that's where populism of the Trump
variety has come from it also damages
doesn't it the kind of constitutional
setup that America is because you you
have this super abundant evidence of
power or or imbalance of power in the
way America was set up in order that
rural parts of America would have a a
proper say which sort of worked didn't
it when it was Republicans and Democrats
who were competing for power in those
rural areas but now if you have that
ossification on party lines that you're
talking about it makes it it really does
strike at the kind of fundamentals of
the Constitution I'm thinking of you
know how the Senate is set up with two
two senators from even tiniest States
etc etc all those things somehow are are
in play they are I mean our our system
is founded on a series of compromises
essentially which were about slavery and
allowing slavery to continue uh after
the uh the formation of the Republic
and that system empowers
small states it empowers rural areas
it creates an electoral college which is
fundamentally undemocratic because you
can win the popular majority and still
lose the election as we see over and
over again famously famously
um and it could be uh our future too
um but when I was young there was a
Democratic senator from South Dakota his
name was George McGovern he was the most
liberal member of the Senate there were
Democrats from Iowa I forgot that they
came from South Dakota that was an
extraordinary fact it was a Democrat
from Idaho named Frank Church very
liberal and these were also really great
Senators so the red blue divide which
really became entrenched starting around
the year 2000. as favored Republicans
because
the anti-democratic structure of our
government with the Senate the Electoral
College and other things too
gerrymandering of political districts
has played into the Republican hands so
that they can hold on to power
with a minority vote and that's become
the cause of a lot of bitterness among
Democrats who want to change the
institutions I don't think they are
going to be changed
and also to the public who sense that
their vote
actually doesn't matter so what if
there's an electoral college
this can overrule the majority why
should I vote but I wanted to say Justin
the other thing that's gone wrong is
simply our ability to govern ourselves
to solve problems together and I think
that's related to inequality in the
sense that
although I don't want to romanticize the
Past in any way because it gave us
slavery segregation and all kinds of
wrongs
the Elites at least felt some obligation
to deal with each other in the interest
of the public maybe their own public but
in the interests of the public and now
more and more
our leaders are are
um
it seemed to have no sense that they
have an obligation to solve problems
instead they are rewarded by the voters
not for solving problems but for
pandering for parading on Twitter and on
cable news for making a name and a brand
for themselves they're more in it for
themselves than to represent the public
and it's not only true of the elites
ordinary Americans simply can't have
these conversations that are essential
to solving problems you don't govern a
democracy by pure force of numbers you
also have to bring people along or else
eventually you're going to run into a
backlash and today we no longer know how
to do that instead each side sees the
other as a mortal adversary that has to
be destroyed and Trump brought us a long
way toward that by behaving that way by
being the first president to make no
pretense of governing the entire country
and representing all Americans well I've
got an easy solution to that just of
social media amen I'm not on it Justin
but it are you not I'm not I avoided it
uh all my career and and you know I've
paid a bit of a price because I'm sort
of a non-edity as far as social media
goes but it is poison it corrodes
the veins of our discourse it it seems
to uh to privilege contempt contempt is
the language of social media and
contempt to me is antithetical to
democracy in which for me democracy
means you have to have a minimal respect
for your fellow citizens in order for
this to work otherwise you're going to
end up where we are which is unable to
solve problems from covid to global
warming to inequality uh Etc so among
the many problems that need to be faced
up to is is that one of them and of
course there is I mean actually to an
extent a bipartisan effort isn't that to
to look particularly at Facebook
um but but also at other social media
places as well and say we've got to do
something about this and actually it's
to an extent I suppose it's it's
worldwide it was it David Rhodes who
said Facebook was the biggest threat to
free freedom and democracy around the
world David Rosie used to work for a
Barack Obama anyway there is this kind
of sense isn't that something needs to
be done so when you're when we we
started with renewal and the things that
need to be done is that also one of the
things that needs to happen is a I'm not
sure we're going to get to what the
solution might be but actually a
thorough going conversation about who's
in charge when it comes to social media
I think so I mean of course like
everything else the debate over social
media quickly devolves into a well
you're for hatred well you're for
censorship
when you put it that way there's no
debate to be had you can't debate
someone who's for hatred you can't
debate someone who wants to censor you
and unfortunately that is the default of
our of our discourse to go to those
extremes but I think this is an issue
where Democrats and Republicans might
find some common ground because there is
an antipathy toward big Tech on both
sides but there's also so much money
coming from Big Tech uh and that's
another deep problem in our inability to
govern ourselves is the absolute rule of
of big money in Washington
um that I don't know if if they'll ever
get it done but there's some obvious
regulations that could be looked at have
the algorithms made public uh have the
algorithms uh be unable to Target
advertising in certain ways
um just in basic things that could be
done that don't suppress speech but that
Force the the tech corporations to stop
uh poisoning the well in a way that
makes us hate each other quite so much
we'll still hate each other but it
doesn't have to be
so bad that it's easy enough for Putin
to put a few drops more into the well
for everything to go bad which is what's
happened